[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís en emisión
de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español en la que cada semana damos
la palabra a artistas gente de las
ciencias de las artes de la política y
de la sociedad civil el presidente
emmanuel macrón perdió la mayoría
absoluta que tenía en la asamblea
nacional los resultados de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones legislativas
celebradas el 19 de junio dieron una
mayoría relativa a la coalición ansanm
el representante del oficialismo la nube
es la nueva unión popular ecológica y
social una alianza de partidos de
izquierdas se convirtió en el primer
grupo de la oposición finalmente la
formación de extrema derecha rn logró un
resultado histórico rodrigo arenas ganó
en el décimo distrito de parís bajo la
etiqueta de la nubes y acabas de hacer
su entrada por primera vez en la nueva
asamblea nacional el equivalente de la
cámara de diputados en francia rodrigo
arenas bienvenidos a esta escala en
parís muchas veces por la invitación
decíamos las nubes hay que recordar es
una coalición de cuatro partidos de
izquierda está la franja insumisa el
partido socialista los ecologistas
hasta el partido comunista francés a las
nubes se ha convertido en la segunda
fuerza política de este país tras las
elecciones del pasado domingo no
obstante no logró los dos principales
objetivos que se habían fijado su
principal dirigente y al look - jon
convertirse en primer ministro y ser el
que tuviese mayor número de diputados en
la nueva asamblea nacional hay un
fracaso en este terreno
en realidad el fracaso no es tan fuerte
porque logramos unirnos después de una
elección presidencial en la cual todo
decía que la izquierda estaba muerta en
realidad tuvo la capacidad de reunirse
detrás de un programa y llevarlo a la
asamblea nacional y probablemente si lo
hubiéramos hecho las nubes o sea
reunirnos sobre ideas para para reparar
la francia en realidad hubiera habido
mucho menos diputado de izquierda en
asamblea nacional pero hay una cosa que
llamó la atención al público francés en
general el domingo y es que en su
discurso el señor jean luc mélenchon no
hizo ninguna referencia al tema de que
él quería ser el primer ministro francés
como si nunca hubiera hecho esa
propuesta lo que pasa que la propuesta
que nosotros decíamos es de devolver al
parlamentos sus letras de nobleza en
realidad estaban un par en francés en
una relación directa entre el presidente
la república y el pueblo como que es el
parlamento no existiera porque
tradicionalmente francia está
acostumbrada después de la elección
presidencial tienen una mayoría muy
confortable para el presidente que fue
electo por primera vez de muchos años el
parlamento no tiene la mayoría del
presidente de la república y eso es un
acontecimiento político muy importante
porque significa que van a tener que
cambiar de modo de gobernar porque
definitivamente el parlamento va a tomar
un lugar muy importante en la vida
política francesa y en particular en las
políticas públicas que va a tener que se
recibía en el parlamento porque no se
puede pasar ninguna ley ningún decreto y
nada si el parlamento no la autoriza
deseamos las nubes está constituida por
cuatro fuerzas políticas no bien se
dieron a conocer los resultados de la
segunda vuelta de las legislativas
una vez más y aluminio dijo llamó a
constituir un grupo único dentro de la
asamblea nacional hubo una respuesta
radical tajante de los otros partidos el
partido socialista el partido comunista
y los verdes diciendo que no porque no
había sido esto un acuerdo de principios
y sobre todo porque no los consultó cómo
puede ser que se lancen una propuesta de
este tipo sin consultar a sus
contrapartes en realidad
y yo te recibo mensaje por ejemplo en
por messenger o twitter lo que sea por
gente que votó por mí en la elección
legislativa y lo que me dicen es decir
no rompan la unión porque nosotros no
votamos por un partido si no votaban por
un movimiento votamos por una alianza
molt votamos para que la izquierda
vuelva a gobernar este país entonces ahí
está la meta en la meta no es solamente
que planchan sea primer ministro sino
como logramos hacer que lo que nosotros
nos fundó un programa de más de 600
proposiciones que están escritas que
están en internet que se pueden bajar
libremente para que esas soluciones se
pongan en lugar en francia y esa es la
meta que se necesita y en realidad esta
proposición quiso yonic menos yo que no
significa hacer desaparecer a los
partidos es dejar un poco que cada cual
juega en su club de fútbol pero también
tenemos que ser capaces de reunirnos
para jugar todos en el mismo equipo de
francia esta es la función que se hace
con pelé la técnica no lo puede
sobrepasar sobre el interés nacional que
nosotros pensamos llevar ahora también
se hacen reacción porque entró de manera
masiva en la extrema derecha al
parlamento y es una respuesta política
que tenemos que dar porque esa no puede
ser la opción para nuestro país porque
macrón que uno lo quiera o nos sirvió de
de escala para que la extrema derecha
pueden traer el gobierno ejemplo de lo
que le estoy diciendo porque por ejemplo
la segunda vuelta más de 60 candidatos
de macrón no llamaron a votar por los
candidatos del grupo frente a la extrema
derecha concretamente cuando nosotros ya
vamos a decir que ningún voto tiene que
ir a la extrema derecha elección
presidencia por la segunda vuelta vemos
qué macon está en la incapacidad de dar
la mano del otro lado porque
concretamente él no decidió entre la
extrema derecha y la izquierda porque
concretamente le sirve ese juego
político que a mí ni que de mi punto de
vista es muy
peligroso para la república porque no
defendimos la misma francia 12 y macro
me tienen que hacer una elección se alía
con la extrema derecha o viene hacia la
izquierda porque el interés general
somos nosotros las democracias somos
nosotros la igualdad somos nosotros no
espero que él no tome la opción de ir
hacia organizaciones políticas que
violan la discriminación el racismo y
muchas veces la igualdad de tratamiento
que los franceses recordemos la cámara
diputados la asamblea nacional está
compuesta por 577 y diputados la mayoría
son 289 usted lo decía por ejemplo la
asamblea nacional las fuerzas de extrema
derecha son 89 diputados ustedes sacan
aproximadamente 142 si no mal recuerdo
las fuerzas de macrón tienen una mayoría
relativa con quién se va a liar
la fuerza de ustedes las nubes para
buscar hacer pasar precisamente la serie
de propuestas éstas evidentemente no las
600 y tantas propuestas que han hecho
pero propuestas fundamentales que
ustedes han venido planteando sobre todo
sabiendo también que tienen divergencias
entre ustedes en puntos como tiene que
ver con lo nuclear y otros aspectos
fundamentales en el programa y punto
sobre el cual estamos de acuerdo y
algunos que no estamos de acuerdo no con
la finalidad sino sobre el camino para
llegar a esa finalidad que sea el
nuclear y otros asuntos lo que va a
suceder es que francia va a tener que
cambiar de cultura política quiere decir
que de tener una una situación en el
cual presiente la república tiene la
mayoría absoluta en el parlamento eso ya
no existe significa que van a tener que
cambiar probablemente y para inspirar lo
de lo que como funciona a europa en
mayoría de proyectos significa que macro
o quien sea la persona que gobierne
dentro poco va a tener que aliarse no
sólo nos obligan electoralistas sino
sobre alianzas de proyecto que sí
cambien el cotidiano y el diario y bien
de la gente por ejemplo el sábado el día
antes de la elección legislativa en
parís hubieron más de 40 grados
que no sea de izquierda de derecha del
norte del sur negro blanco todo el mundo
está afectado por la calor y la
habitación los modos de transporte las
escuelas los lugares para ancianos los
hospitales no están adaptados y
construidos para soportar esa vasta
temperatura o sea la la brutalidad en el
cual los cambios climáticos por ejemplo
golpean a francia eso es un trabajo de
preocupación de interés general dentro
un cuadro nacional entonces macro me
tenéis que hacer esa elección y la
rapidez de estar en ruptura con el
modelo económico social y ecológico en
el cual está implantado francia se va a
imponer a todo el mundo y en eso
nosotros tenemos muchas proposiciones y
no pensamos evidentemente que maicon
tiene que tener la misma sí pero yo le
doy pase a una pregunta muy concreta con
quienes se pueden ustedes a liar al
interior de la asamblea nacional para
hacer pasar propuestas concretas muy
precisas por ejemplo la frase un símil
la asociación la que usted pertenece ha
planteado la necesidad de evolucionar de
la quinta a la sexta república ninguna
transformación política comparte este
punto de vista entonces cómo hacer para
evolucionar y justamente sobrepasar esta
situación de crisis en la que estamos
metidos ahora tras los resultados de las
legislativas las alianzas no van a hacer
alianza tradicional entre partidos van a
hacer alianzas sobre proyectos y sobre
leyes quieren que mejoren el de la vida
a la gente ahora no hay que odiar
también que nosotros venimos también
conmigo del momento social significa que
los sindicatos las federaciones de
apoderados y de padres de alumnos
todo lo que comporte la sociedad civil
va a tener una implicación muy fuerte en
lo que vamos a hacer porque estamos
llegado a eso por ejemplo yo no fui
elegido solamente por la lf fue elegido
por un conjunto de partido y también un
conjunto de electores significa que mi
responsabilidad en mi circunscripción va
a ser de hacer vivir las nubes para que
la gente que se moviliza al cotidiano en
la vida de dolor díaz en los sindicatos
en hospitales escuela en los barrios va
a tener que tener una implicación y eso
va a ser la facilidad el modo en el cual
vamos a poder cambiar las cosas el
debate no se puede encerrar en la
asamblea nacional porque hay mucha gente
que empuja y tiene afán de cambiar la
sociedad entonces cuando uno habla de la
república número 6 de la sexta pública
concretamente de que estamos hablando
del modelo chileno que logró con muchos
años que hacer cambiar la constitución
si lo logró chile no hay ninguna razón
que france no no puede ser pero es un
proceso que tenemos que hacer porque si
la ciudadanía no se implica y si no
logramos nosotros en tanto de diversa
política implica la ciudadanía entonces
eso va a ser una revolución de palacio
nosotros queremos una revolución
ciudadana
justamente usted decía usted viene del
movimiento social ignacio en chile
ciertamente durante varios años ha
participado en la federación de consejos
de familiares de familias de alumnos
entre el 2018 y el 2021 su trabajo y
usted durante ese tiempo denunció
precisamente la crisis que está viviendo
el sistema educativo francés ese va a
ser el eje fundamental de su actividad
digamos por ejemplo ahora que estoy
desde diputado o pienso ustedes impulsar
propuestas de propuestas de ley a este
respecto hay un grupo en la asamblea
nacional del cual yo pertenezco y
evidentemente voy a hacer la proposición
de trabajar sobre los asuntos educativos
universitarios y también culturales
si el grupo está de acuerdo que no lo
haré pero si estoy en otro grupo tampoco
me voy a enojar porque hay mucho trabajo
y como somos varios vamos repartir lo
mejor pero evidentemente voy a tener una
visión muy
exigente sobre ese punto por ejemplo hay
proposiciones de ley que pueden salir
muy pronto a nosotros cuando el primer
día no entregaron un maletín un maletín
con con todos los sustentos y les que
son necesarios para trabajo
parlamentario y eso es gratis el gratis
o sea que quiere decir que está pagado
por el impuesto los diputados se tratan
bien en realidad entonces yo espero que
al cabo de cinco años cuando termine mi
mandato en todos los aludes de francia
todos los profesores también van a poder
tener con cualquier parlamentario los
ostensibles para poder hacer su trabajo
lo que no es el caso hoy día que
significa que ya tenemos que cambiar del
hecho que para ir a la escuela los
padres y los profesores tienen que poner
la tarjeta de crédito además de la
obligación del estado de dar la
educación gratuita para poder tener una
enseñanza normal eso hoy día no existen
los de guarenas de manera muy breve el
gobierno el presidente macro ha llamado
ha evocado la posibilidad de un gobierno
de unidad nacional cuál es la respuesta
que usted a eso yo creo que tiene que
tener cuidado con las palabras que
utiliza porque unión nacional significa
la alianza de partidos pero sin la
izquierda y sin el partido comunista
entonces hay que tomar muy precisamente
las palabras nosotros como como le decía
estamos en capacidad de proponer
alternativas para el país entonces claro
de una manera tradicional porque así
funciona somos un grupo de oposición en
la asamblea nacional porque así se
traduce para poder tener algunos puestos
en particular el asunto de la comisión
de finanzas que de manera reglamentaria
le viene al primer grupo de oposición
por eso también la nube es importante y
que los partidos tienen que quedarse
junto pero también son una fuerza
alternativa y esa es la meta la meta es
como le decía en el parlamento como
logramos convencer a los otros grupos
para hacer leyes y proposiciones de
políticas públicas en lazo con el
gobierno para poder ser avanzan las
cosas porque que uno sea otra vez desde
lo digo o sea que seamos de izquierda a
derecha o del norte del sur todos
estamos confrontados a los muy problemas
pero no tenemos todas las soluciones
vamos a conversar de las soluciones y la
ciudadanía podrá jugar tendremos ocasión
de hablar de eso en la próxima ocasión
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a rodrigo arenas dispensado
del décimo distrito de parís y de la
nubes y de las famosas y ni su presencia
en nuestros estudios muy amable yo creo
que a ustedes les damos una nueva cita
aquí la próxima semana en otra escala en
parís
[Música]